do you think um
knowing or learning how the sausage is
made
ruins the magic of the actual experience
like
use a neuroscientist who studies the
brain do you think it
ruins the magic of like love at first
sight
are you do you consciously are still
able to lose yourself in the moment
i'm definitely able to lose myself in
the moment is wine involved
not always chocolate i mean some kind of
mind altering some students right but
um yeah for sure i mean i guess what i
would say though is that um
[Music]
for me part of the magic is the process
like so uh you know so so i remember
a day there was while i was working on
this on this on this book of essays i
i was in new york um i can't remember
why i was in new york but i was in new
york for something
and i was in central park and i was
looking at all the
people with their babies and i was
thinking
every every each one of these there's a
tiny little brain
that's wiring itself right now and i
and i i just i felt in that moment i was
like i am
never going to look at an infant in the
same way ever again
and so to me i mean honestly before i
started learning about brain development
i thought babies were cute but you know
not that interesting until they could do
interact with you and do things of
course my own infant i thought was
extraordinarily interesting but
you know they're kind of like lumps
that's you know until they can
you know interact with you but they are
anything but lumps i mean like
you know so and part of the
i mean i i all i can say is i have deep
affection now for like
tiny little babies in a way that i
didn't really
um before um because
of the i'm just so curious
but the actual process the mechanisms of
the the wiring of the brain the learning
all the magic of the neurobiology
yeah and or you know something like
you know um when you make eye contact
with someone directly
sometimes you know you
you feel something right yeah and
um that's weird what is it and what is
that
and so so to me that's not um that's not
backing away from the moment that's like
expanding the moment it's like that's
incredibly cool
you know when i was um i'll just say
that when i was
when i was in graduate school i also
was in therapy because it's almost a
given that you're going to be in therapy
yourself
if you're going to become a therapist
and i had a deal
you know with my therapist which was
that i could call time out at any moment
that i wanted to
as long as i was being responsible about
it and i wasn't using it as a way to get
out of something
and he could tell me no you know he
could decline and say no we're you're
you know you're using this to get out of
something but
i could call time out whenever i want
and say what are you doing right now
like what are you
here's what i'm experiencing what are
you trying to do like i wanted to use my
own experience to interrogate um
what the process was and
that made it
more helpful in a way do you know what i
mean so yeah i don't
i don't think learning how something
works makes it less magical actually
but that's just me i guess i don't know
would you
uh yes i tend to uh
have two modes one is one is an engineer
and one is uh romantic
and i'm conscious of like like the gear
like
you like there's two rooms you can go
into the one the engineer room and i
think that ruins the romance so
i tend to there's two rooms one is the
engineering room
think from first principles how do we
build the thing that creates this kind
of uh
behavior and then you go into the
romantic room where you're like
emotional it's a roller coaster and then
you're uh the thing is let's take it
slow and then you get married the next
night that
you just this giant mess and you write a
song and then
you cry and then you just send a bunch
of text and anger and
and whatever and somehow you're in vegas
and there's random people and you're
drunk and whatever all that like in
poetry and just mess of it
fighting yeah yeah that's not those are
two rooms
and you go back between between them but
i think the way you put it is quite
poetic
i think you're much you're much better
at adulting
uh with love than uh
than perhaps i am because there's a
magic to children
i also think
like of adults as children it's kind of
cool to see
it's a cool thought experiment to look
at adults and think like
that used to be a baby and then that's
like a fully wired baby
and it's just walking around pretending
to be like all serious and important
wearing a suit or something but i used
to be a baby
and then you think of like the parenting
and all the experiences they had
like it's cool to think of it that way
but then you i start thinking like from
a machine learning perspective
but once you're like the romantic
moments all that kind of stuff
all that falls away i forget about all
that
i don't know that's the russian thing
you